deux lieutenants des vaccins à chef des
forces armées canadiennes années 90 54
ans prend la tête de la défense
nationale elle qui était jusqu'à présent
ministre des services publics et de
l'approvisionnement ainsi qu'elle ne
soit en aide sa nomination arrive un
moment délicat pour l'armée canadienne
embourbé dans plusieurs scandales
d'inconduite sexuelle impliquant des
hauts gradés sans commenter ces
allégations directement un nouvel hymne
istres s'est dit prête à relever le défi
je suis axé sur les résultats
donc ce sont des qualités que je vais
apporter à ce dossier la tâche qui en
face d'elle est équivalente à monter le
- brest mais la nomination d'une femme à
la défense ne suffira pas pour changer
la culture au sein de l'armée croit
cette experte le travail qu'elle a
devant elle c'est pas un travail qu'elle
peut faire en quelques mois ou même en
un an ça va être des efforts continus et
répété
dans la circonscription d'anita end en
banlieue ouest de toronto ses partisans
s'attendaient à une promotion on frappe
sur le sur le bois là le président de
l'association libérale du comté crois
que la ministre a brillé dans son
portfolio précédent où elle a conclu des
ententes pour obtenir plus de 400
millions de doses de vaccin était déjà
chevronné dans l'amour dans le monde
académique dans le monde juridique elle
a travaillé tellement fort avec les
vaccins tout le monde à travers le
canada a vu son travail assidu plusieurs
électeurs abonde dans le même sens
vacciné
j'espère le meilleur pour elle d'autres
soulignent néanmoins que nissan n'a pas
d'expérience militaire contrairement à
son prédécesseur arbitrage anne
au-delà de la question de l'inconduite
sexuels au sein de l'armée anita allen
sera confronté à d'autres enjeux majeurs
cyber sécurité défense de l'arctique
conflits asymétriques
autant de dossiers qui pourraient
compliquer le mandat de la nouvelle
patronne des forces armées canadiennes
ici est le média radio canada oakville